before the Seven Kingdoms before the
Iron Throne
there was Dorne 12,000 years ago the
first men crossed the land bridge from
Essos to here of course there were men
so they soon broke it
then while their cousins to the north
build kingdoms the Dornish squabbled
over land water and wives for centuries
until nine mariya a warrior princess in
Essos she led a fleet of ten thousand
ships across the Narrow Sea to Dorne
almost all of the petty Lords made it
clear that she wasn't welcome all but
one mores of house Martell he saw in her
strength too much any man including his
rivals after she accepted his marriage
offer she set fire to her ships 450
leaves the coast was bright as day and
in the burning light princess name area
named more smart tell the Prince of
Dorne in the style of her people dawn
would be her home or her grave for many
years Nymeria and Mors waged war against
all rivals the jordanes Blackmun's korg
isles and even the mighty house iron
wood they sent no fewer than six
self-styled
kings to the wall in golden chains after
mores fell in battle Nymeria took
command of his armies and United Dorne
in two years she ruled for twenty-seven
more and though she murdered again those
husbands were little more than
councilors and consorts Dorne was nigh
Maria and I'm area was Dorne she
survived a dozen attempts on her life
put down two rebellions and threw back
to invasions and when at last she died
her eldest child succeeded her her
daughter not her son and Dorne followed
her because Nigeria had proven that
women were equal to men if not better
centuries later Aegon Targaryen sought
to unite Westeros as my Mary had Dorne
the other six kingdoms fell quickly
before his dragons and ambition when his
sister-wife Rainey's flew her dragons
south and demanded our surrender as well
Princess Marya Martell warned I will not
fight you
nor will I kneel to you dawn has no king
tell your brother that rain is
threatened that the next time the
Targaryen would come with fire and blood
Maria replied you may burn us milady but
you will not Bend us break us or make us
bow this is Dorne you are not wanted
here
return at your peril Rhaenys did and she
died her dragon died all her soldiers
died eventually her brother the
Conqueror conceded that what Nymeria had
done he could not undo generations later
another foolish Targaryen invaded Dorne
he died as well eventually we did join
the Seven Kingdoms but when we wanted
and on our terms
if dragons could not conquer us why
should we fear lions unbowed unbent
unbroken the words of house Martell
the words of Dorne men may forget but
women always remember when we were
divided Nymeria United us when we were
invaded Maria defended us now Dorne has
been humiliated its Prince murdered who
will rise to avenge us